après le meurtre de la petite ludivine
médecins et psychologues retour les
élèves qui sont rentrés chez eux
le suspect le cuisinier du camp est
passé aux aveux
arrivée de jean paul ii cet après midi
au nigeria pour une visite de trois
jours
accueil enthousiaste et déclarations du
saint père sur les droits de l'homme la
fête de l'internet avec le portrait de
son inventeur il est américain il est
passionné d'informatique ça l'humanisme
qui a mis au point 74 ce réseau qui
diffuse dans le monde entier le village
de bourg peronnas en émoi avant le match
demain soir de son équipe face à lyon en
quart de finale de la coupe de france de
football
tous les espoirs madame monsieur bonsoir
les réactions se multiplient après la
fracture à droite qui s'est produite
hier avec l'élection de cinq présidents
de régions grâce aux voix du front
national lourde de conséquences
cette nouvelle donne appel commentaires
analyses mais à la veille des élections
cantonales le code électoral nous
interdit de rendre compte demain soir
bien évidemment nous consacrerons une
édition spéciale à cette actualité
politique
aujourd'hui après l'élection de charles
millon à la présidence de la région
rhône alpes plusieurs centaines de
personnes ont manifesté à lyon pour
réclamer la démission de celui qui a été
réélu à la tête du conseil avec les voix
du front national jean baptiste près
d'ayer quelques pancartes et des unes de
journaux pour protester
la belle cour a lyon ils étaient un
millier environ ce matin première
réaction de lyonnais militants ou non à
l'élection d'hier j'ai l'âme
républicaine non ce n'est pas ce que je
veux savoir 78 non que j'aie connu la
montée du nazisme en allemagne et que je
ne vais pas de nouvelles je suis
effondré par ce qui s'est passé hier
effondrait de voir qu'un élu comme
millions est incapable de démissionner
une fois qu'il a accepté les voix du
front national comme avec ma région
sénat jean camille âge c'est quand même
vraiment récente de ma région
les partis de gauche et les mouvements
de lutte contre l'extrême droite
appellent à manifester à nouveau mardi à
lyon mais ce matin on en est resté au
dépôt d'une gerbe devant le veilleur de
pierre
c'est le monument lyonnais à la
résistance bernard besson vice président
du groupe udf à l'assemblée a demandé à
charles million de démissionner le
député maire d'annecy affirme qu'en
politique le déshonneur ça n'est pas
d'être battu c'est d'accepter une
semblable élections fin de citation et
puis sur une toute autre voie françois
d'aubert vice-président de démocratie
libérale déclare quant à lui que la
droite a eu raison de faire barrage ou
socialo communistes et à l'extrême
gauche
enfin une nouvelle mise en garde de
philippe séguin le président du rpr
déclare qu'il est hors de question qu'un
membre du parti gaulliste accepte de
participer à l'exécutif d'une région
conquise avec les voix du front national
et puis il y à quelques instants nous
avons appris que le front national
revendiquer la présidence de la région
provence alpes côte d'azur au nom de la
réciprocité le parti de jean-marie le
pen
après l'élection vendredi de cinq
présidents de régions grâce au front
national prévient qu'il déterminera son
attitude en ile-de-france en haute
normandie et en midi pyrénées en
fonction de cette réciprocité dans la
région paca carte après le meurtre de la
petite ludivine ses camarades de classe
sont rentrés chez eux pris en charge par
des médecins et des psychologues
certains d'entre eux aurait été victime
d'attouchements sexuels le suspect qui
sera présenté au parquet demain et le
cuisinier du centre il est passé aux
aveux
vincent nguyen philippe visseyrias
vraiment très fermement fort là
maintenant
admirable que quand vous le verrez si je
ne sais pas ce devait être les
retrouvailles joyeuses d'une fin de
classe de neige mais les visages sont
tendus 1 qui s'est entouré de
psychologue que les enfants sont arrivés
ce matin à peine plus de 10 ans est
témoin d'un drame
les enfants semblent pourtant moins
choqué que leurs parents bien sûr ils
vont souffrir un petit peu mais ça c'est
tout à fait naturel
il y en a qui ont pleuré il commence à
bas à parler pas mal et je trouve que
c'est très intéressant pour pour eux et
je pense que je suis pas trop inquiet
pour le suivi de ces enfants par la
suite à la gendarmerie hier soir le
suspect avoue cuisinier au centre de
vacances il s'est introduit dans les
chambres a touché plusieurs fillettes
avant de s'en prendre à ludivine on
retrouvera son corps dans la salle de
bain la toxi confirme les déclarations
que j'appelle début d'aveu l'intéressé à
savoir qu'elle l'a bien être anglais
mais pas violent le soir du drame ce
toulousain de 27 ans avait bu ça ne
suffit pas à expliquer son geste
surtout pas pour sa mère accablé
d'incompréhension et qui avaient des
faits divers comme ça à la télévision
c'était lui le premier qui disait marx
et des boîtes de [ __ ] il faut les tuer
bon voilà et là bon c'est pour ça je
n'arrive pas à comprendre ce qui s'est
passé je ne sais pas il sait pas du tout
le suspect sera présenté demain au
parquet en attendant l'enquète continue
pour éclaircir les circonstances du
drame tenté notamment d'expliquer
pourquoi les filles qui se sont plaintes
d'attouchements sexuels n'ont pas appelé
à l'aide des adultes qui dormait à côté
pour la troisième fois en deux semaines
mobilisation des enseignants et des
parents d'élèves de seine-saint-denis
2000 manifestants dans les rues de la
capitale pour obtenir un véritable plan
d'urgence pour l'école dans ce
département sinistré une délégation a
été reçue commissaire de l'éducation
dans les côtes d'armor les écologistes
s'inquiètent des risques que
représentent les pendage déboute de l'
usine d'équarrissage une usine
spécialisée depuis la crise de la vache
folle dans la destruction de déchets à
risques de leur côté les pouvoirs
publics se veulent rassurants jacques
devaux gabriel kenya les militants d'eau
et rivières ne décolère pas
juge inadmissible que l' usine
d'équarrissage de plouvara puis
s'épandre les boues de stations
d'épuration dans les champs environnants
deschamps qui donne sur le leff une
rivière qui alimente 22000 personnes en
eau potable
ces bourses elles proviennent des rejets
de l'entreprise serge est ce sont les
eaux usées qui servent à la cuisson des
produits transformés
ce sont les rejets les eaux de lavage
des camions des véhicules ce sont les
jus des cadavres qui arrive en état de
décomposition serre ges et tout ça et
c'est ça qu'on est pas aujourd'hui sur
les terres agricoles du bassin versant
lusine de plouvara depuis la crise de la
vache folle a détruit on ce troupeau est
apparue la maladie
mais selon les services vétérinaires les
animaux atteints de sb ont été détruits
ailleurs aucune et va à ploufragan qui
dispose d'un incinérateur louvard à n'a
traité que le reste du troupeau jugé
sain après analyse clinique
lorsqu'on effectue un abattage totale du
cheptel en question l'ensemble des
animaux sont examinées il ne possède
dans tous les cas qu'on a eu aucun
symptôme de le sb ils sont traités à
l'équarrissage
mais ils sont tous cliniquement saint
vache folle ou pas pour henri guyomar
militants d'eau et rivières
l'épandage légale même strictement
contrôlés n'est pas une garantie à la
lumière en épandage sur les champs on ne
peut pas dire personne ne peut dire une
enquête publique est en cours pour
accroître la capacité de l'usiné
d'équarrissage
celle ci prévoit de ne plus dépendre
sebou une solution qui devrait rassurer
les écologistes
quarante cinq mille morts sur les routes
d'europe chaque année les 15 pays de
l'union européenne met au point un texte
qui devrait permettre d'ici quelques
mois de punir tous les chauffards ce
projet envisage la suspension du permis
de conduire après infractions suspension
valable dans les 15 pays
arnaud bouter bernie mériaux
diviser par deux le nombre de tués sur
les routes d'europe d'ici 2001
tel est l'objectif du texte européen
l'accord vise à ce que la déchéance du
permis de conduire soit appliquée dans
les 15 pays de l'union
en clair un automobiliste français
condamné en allemagne ou en angleterre
un retrait de permis ne pourra même plus
roulé en france il existe une volonté
politique unanime pour qu'une sanction
imposée par un état membre soit
également applicable dans un autre état
membre de l'union européenne
la convention se base sur une liste de
plusieurs infractions graves qui vont de
la conduite dangereuse sans permis en
état d'ivresse ont refus de se soumettre
à des éthylotests
il a fallu sept en conseil des ministres
de l'union européenne pour obtenir cet
accord
sept ans pour redéfinir son rôle un
certain nombre de pays membres de
l'union européenne
on peut citer notamment l'angleterre le
danemark l'allemagne considère que
l'union européenne n'est pas compétente
pour réglementer les comportements les
pour les questions économiques et
financières
en france le taux maximal d'alcoolémie
et de 0,5 mg par litre 0,2 en suède 0,8
en grande-bretagne même variations
concernant les vitesses autorisées
une harmonisation européenne est en
cours mais elle prendra de nombreuses
années alors que s'achève la semaine de
la santé mentale voyant l'exemple de ce
réseau créé alliant l écoute des
adolescents en effet les jeunes sont
souvent les plus fragiles
sinon juge le nombre de suicides chaque
année c'est pourquoi un psychiatre
lyonnais eu l'idée de créer une écoute
téléphonique gratuite anonyme et
régionales reportage françoise valais
patrick voie qu'il faut pas lui dire
comme ça à brûle pourpoint brutalement
je pense qu est ce que tu en penses toi
tu es connu quelques écoutes comment
c'est la première fois que tu les
appelles
un numéro vert une bouée pour quelqu'un
qui sont le numéro se transmet de bouche
à oreille
il s'affiche aussi dans le métro les
lycées les cabinets médicaux
créé il ya six ans cap écoute s'adresse
aux êtres doués à tous ceux qui à un
moment de leur vie ou des problèmes
l'idée que j'avais au départ c'était de
permettre à ceux qui est inquiet de d'en
parler éventuellement les coûts
techniques représentant un premier
intermédiaire qui permettait de faire un
pas en avant parce que ce qui te fait
souffrir même peut maintenant c'est que
tu continues de penser à lui
je veux dire oui même dans un groupe
d'amis puis tu verra comment les choses
évoluent maintenant 1 % des appels sont
des jeunes qui ont besoin de parler en
dehors du milieu familial l'appel est
toujours anonyme il en cas de besoin il
peut déboucher rapidement sur une
consultation avec un médecin un
psychiatre une assistante sociale un
troc aux problèmes trop lent au
téléphone et elle lui a très vite
compris elle m'a dirigé donc
actuellement sur 200 en consultation et
c'est vrai je pense j'ai fait le bon
choix qui est une dernière porte de
sortie quoi pour moi et mon fils surtout
pas celle conduite
problèmes de toxicomanie de maltraitance
suicide peur de l'avenir ou problèmes de
coeur ici aucun appel n'est anodin les
parents de base il ya longtemps j'ai
l'impression que l'on s'amuse là
derrière non mais si je t'écoute moi oui
mais non mais parce qu'il ya des gens
qui s'amusent mais toi tu es peut-être
sérieuse alors je t'écoute et
l'expérience nous a appris par que des
jeunes nous ont rappelé à 13 ans dans
louis plusieurs fois j'ai appelé par
avant et depuis j'ai rien osé dire où
j'ai une bêtise
et puis j'ai vu que vous attendiez ou
que ce n'était pas refermé
oui l'an passé l'association a reçu dix
mille appels à cap écoute on peut tout
dire
l'important est d'être là au bout du fil
pour en parler en parler à temps nous
avons suivi depuis le début l'histoire
de la petite céline âgé de 3 ans qui
atteinte d'un cancer rare ne pouvait
être soigné qu'aux états unis grâce à la
solidarité de son village de saint rémy
du nord et de la générosité du public
céline est arrivé hier à boston ses
premiers pas en amérique
reportage philippe gassot céline a
raison il ne fait pas chaud décalage
horaire réveil de bonheur la famille
croit arrivé il ya quelques heures à
boston découvre par une température
polaire ce que sera leur rue pendant
deux mois et demi ce poème siècle par
chez nous ce maroc
ils arrivent à vous habituer oui on
touche est jolie comme le temps de
récupérer un peu et mardi prochain ce
sera l'hôpital tous lés jours
mais avant on prend ses marques c'est
une nouvelle vie qui commence avec ces
embarras et surtout l'espoir grassois la
protonthérapie
voir concrètement on lit double ses
chances c'est à dire qu'elle passe à 80
% de chances de guérison
on sait 1 80% c'est beaucoup mais parle
un sens c'est peu il ya toujours les 20%
restants c'est toujours ses 20% dans one
-celui doit être anesthésié tous les
jours donc on sait pas trop comment ça
va se passer
pour gaël le frère de céline il va
falloir se mettre à l'anglais y lire à
l'école à boston quand ils jouent aux
reporters les questions sont toujours
les mêmes vous avez encore s'est il
tentait ce que vous abaissiez à monsieur
qui veut nuit là et tu vas et qui va te
jette encore chez les parents de céline
se battent ne vivent que dans la seule
idée de pouvoir enfin jeter ce corset ce
cauchemar aux antilles en marge de la
fête internet qui a démarré hier en
france je vous propose de découvrir
l'inventeur d'internet l'homme et
américains c'est en 1974 avec l'un de
ses amis qui l'a mise au point l'
architecture qui permettrait de faire
entrer dans chacun des foyers américains
le réseau pari réussi puisque
aujourd'hui un tiers des adultes aux
états unis sont connectés grâce au génie
de winton certes c'est son nom véritable
humaniste que nous présente
maryse bureau il roule en jaguar ne sort
jamais sans son chapeau et son costume
trois pièces jamais non plus sans une
petite valise
cet homme à l'élégance tout britannique
est américain et s'il n'a pas le look
habituel des fondus d'informatique il
n'en est pas moins considéré comme
l'inventeur de l'internet
on ne s'étonnera donc pas de ce qu'il
transporte dans sa petite valise
qu'est-ce que j'ai là dedans en fait
c'est un ordinateur d'état de file des
convertisseurs et des papiers vinton
cerf est ainsi inséparable de son
ordinateur portable qu'il rebranche dès
qu'il rentre à la maison
vinton cerf ou l'histoire d'un inventeur
heureux car c'est un peu grâce afin
trouva et grâce à l'internet que son
époux autrefois sourde entend
aujourd'hui les mots de son mari c'est
en effet en cherchant sur l'internet
cette immense banque d'informations
qu'elle a appris il ya quelques années
qu'elle pouvait être soignés et opérés
je suis allé sur internet et j'ai trouvé
beaucoup de renseignements sur la
technique des implants et en quelques
semaines j'étais capable de programmer
une date d'opération la possibilité pour
beaucoup de gens de mettre des
informations dans une sorte de poko
c'est à dire sur le net est un moyen
très très puissant de faire se
rencontrer leurs idées et leurs maîtres
vinton cerf est aujourd'hui vice
président de m6 un numéro deux américain
de la téléphonie un véritable cerveau
qui impressionne son staff d'ingénieurs
dans les années 60 ce sont les
militaires américains qui ont inventé
les prémices de l'internet mais en 74
windsurf et l'un de ses amis
imagine l architecture finale qui relie
aujourd'hui via des ordinateurs des
millions de particuliers dans le monde
c'est cette communication de groupe
ce partage qui rompt l'internet simic
c'est en cela que cette technologie est
révolutionnaire vinton cerf est aussi un
grand connaisseur de vins de bordeaux
une passion qui lui vient de france la
france où il a créé une association pour
promouvoir l'internet et faire que notre
pays apprécie autant l'informatique que
le vin en géorgie la violente tornade
qui a touché le nord-est 2
l'état a provoqué la mort de 12
personnes le bilan est lourd 85 blessés
dont certains grièvement
après le passage au petit matin de ce
tourbillon qui a balayé en l'espace de
quelques minutes une zone d'une
vingtaine de kilomètres de long sur 1 km
de large
maisons écoles endommagées caravane de
disloquer de violents incendies qui ont
touché l amazonie brésilienne 72
maintenant les feux de savane et de
forêts touche désormais le venezuela le
guyana et le surinam le feu qui a
démarré au début du mois continue donc
de se propager entretenu par de vents
puissants des villages indiens
pourraient être menacés à pied d'oeuvre
des centaines de pompiers au kosovo à la
veille d'élections clandestine non
reconnue par belgrade élection qui
devrait lire un président et un
parlement officieux la tension est
retombée ce scrutin a une valeur
hautement symbolique renforcer la
légitimité des dirigeants albanais face
au pouvoir serbe reportage laurent
boussier jean-jacques le garrec des
milliers d'antennes paraboliques pour
capter les télévisions étrangères depuis
longtemps quand il se passe quelque
chose d'important chez eux les albanais
du kosovo comme la famille etc à suivre
les informations qui viennent de
l'extérieur c'est le cadre des élections
de demain élections clandestine les
médias locaux tenue par les serbes n'en
parle donc pas alors que pour les
albanais c'est une étape cruciale
il ya neuf ans perial et son mari ont
perdu leur emploi dans l'administration
depuis ils vivent de petits boulots pour
eux la réponse à leur problème est
politique
ces élections doivent nous permettre
d'avoir un gouvernement qui nous amène
vers la stabilité et l'indépendance
selon ruth clandestinité oblige dans les
rues que traverse sperian comme dans
toute la ville aucune affiche électorale
elles sont toutes restées dans les états
majors des partis politiques là cet
après midi des volontaires comptaient
les bulletins distribués élection facile
il n'y a qu'un seul candidat
ibrahim rugova au poste de président
l'enjeu des élections est ailleurs
méthodes les goûts qu'on le veuille ou
non il va falloir négocier avec les
serbes et ces élections donneront une
légitimité à nos négociateurs
elles ont valeur de référendum sur la
politique pacifiste du président hugo
boss ou accéder à l'indépendance
mais ces élections ne font pas
l'unanimité chez les albanais au moins
un grand parti regrette qu'elles aient
lieu en ce moment
normalement on ne peut pas d'un côté
compter les bulletins de vote et en même
temps compter les blessés on ne peut pas
faire des élections dans un pays en état
de guerre
ces divisions entre albanais à la veille
de ces élections font évidemment le
bonheur des serbes qui depuis quelques
jours multiplient les manifestations
nationalistes pour essayer de faire
monter la tension
arrivée du pape jean paul 2 cet après
midi au nigeria accueil enthousiaste
vingt mille personnes ont ovationné le
saint père dès son arrivée le pape a
demandé le respect des droits de l'homme
et rendu hommage à tous ceux qui
travaillent pour la paix en afrique sur
place alain me salvant les nigérians
n'ont pas voulu manquer leur rendez vous
avec le pape
rendez vous qui a même parfois tourné
quasiment à l'émeute
tout cela pour voir jean paul ii qui
était arrivée peu avant à l'aéroport
d'abuja la nouvelle capitale du nigeria
contraste avec la cérémonie protocolaire
militaires comme le régime de ce pays le
plus important d'afrique avec ses 100
millions d'habitants
militarisation qui n'exclut pas les
concours d'élégance
la mode est très jean paul lieu en ce
moment à abuja le président nigérian lui
même le général abacha avait troqué son
éternel uniforme pour un superbe
bouilloire les deux hommes se sont
salués cordialement comme il se doit ce
qui n'a pas empêché jean paul ii de
parler franchement des droits de l'homme
dans son discours aux forces il vous
faut promouvoir harmonie et unité
nationale garantir la vie humaine et les
droits de l'homme en parlant ainsi jean
paul ii va à la rencontre des
préoccupations des nigérians qui
souhaite ardemment un peu plus de
démocratie et un peu moins de répression
me woods a pour la visite du pape va
aider à résoudre les problèmes des
droits de l'homme au nigeria
on va avoir beaucoup de progrès ici il
va apporter paix et unité au nigeria
l'unité de ce pays c'est aussi celle de
ses communautés religieuses musulmans et
chrétiens se partagent le nigeria à peu
près également mais se livre aussi à une
compétition féroce comme en témoigne la
guerre des chantiers à bouge à celui de
la mosquée est terminée alors que celui
de la cathédrale est en panne faute
d'argent
le nigeria avait beaucoup de marabouts
musulmans mais n'avait pas encore de
saint catholiques ce sera fait demain
jean paul ii procédera à onitsha au
coeur du pays boos à la première
béatification d'un africains de l'ouest
est non seulement on vient de le dire le
pape devrait donc lors de ce voyage de
trois jours béatifié un moine cistercien
et ce au moment précisément ou l'abbaye
de cîteaux en côte d'or célèbre son 900e
anniversaire anniversaire de la
fondation de cet ordre dont la règle et
la pauvreté venue des monastères du
monde entier 700 religieux et
religieuses ou communier dans la prière
et le chant grégorien marie-hélène bono
pascal pessiot l'abbaye a ouvert ses
grilles ce matin à l'aube pour
accueillir les reliques de saint robert
le fondateur du monde
le 21 mars 1098 robert de molesme
arriver d'ici avec 21 moines pour
perpétuer la règle de saint benoît
pauvreté ville en chasse de tes prières
ce matin quelque 700 moines et moniales
se retrouvaient pour commémorer cet
anniversaire une baisse de plus de trois
heures dans une abbatiale moderne
modernes comme le message délivré par le
chef spirituel de l'abbaye au fond du
coeur de tout homme de toute femme il ya
une aspiration profonde à la paix et à
une vraie paix c'est très exigeant
c'est très passionnant et je crois que
c'est ce qui peut nous réunir tous
l'ordre des cisterciens compte 8000
religieux répartis dans 47 pays
cette cérémonie aujourd'hui était pour
eux comme une fête de famille
je suis très ému devant cette de voir
cette universalité de l'ordre cistercien
ça me touche beaucoup et je suis content
d'être là c'est la première fois que je
vais aussi en france vous venez d'où je
viens de madagascar monastère de ma
ronde et ensemble ils ont célébré
l'eucharistie puis partager leur repas
un moment en dehors du temps pour les
trente cinq moines de cîteaux qui ne
sortent jamais de leurs mômes de silence
et de prière
un ordre qui a survécu au siècle en
gardant la règle monastique la plus
stricte du monde chrétien
à l'occasion de l'ouverture du salon du
livre nous avons tenté de voir comment
les français avaient accès à la lecture
à travers les bibliothèques municipales
l'exemple de roanne avec l'un des plus
beaux édifices qui donne l'envié et le
goût de lire l'enquète de geneviève moll
et d'alain du bas
cet enfant a de la chance on lui a
construit la médiathèque la plus moderne
de france dans une ville de 76 mille
habitants comme roanne qui a perdu
beaucoup d'emplois en 20 ans c'était un
pari risqué
pourtant depuis son ouverture il y a
quatre mois les roannais se sont emparés
du lieu
ils y viennent en famille même avec les
tout-petits pourrez lire un journal un
magazine une revue pour y faire des
recherches choisir leur lecture
21% des rohan et sont inscrits à la
bibliothèque
ces quatre points de plus que la moyenne
nationale mais la ville a depuis un
siècle
une vraie tradition de lecture
populaires y avait à l'intérieur de ces
services une biotech populaire qui avait
animé à l'époque
jusque dans les années 60 par des
instituteurs bénévoles qui se chargeait
de manière militante de promouvoir le
roman populaire héritiers de
effectivement des zola et autres auprès
d'une population à majorité ouvrir cette
population a un peu évolué ce sont
davantage les classes moyennes qui
fréquentent aujourd'hui la médiathèque
mais ce sont toujours les romans qui a
terrain ses lecteurs voilà j'ai choisi
sa jeunesse in j'ai lu la journée d'ivan
denissovitch et puis j'ai pas lu et 2e
tour et puis allez je connais pas même
un peu solide et pour nouvelle les
enfants eux adorent ce lieu ils y
viennent bien sur place choisir leurs
livres pour la semaine des romans et des
bd en général y faire leurs devoirs
mais surtout la médiathèque met à la
disposition des vecteurs des ordinateurs
alors là pour les enfants c'est le
bonheur complet
chaque fois que je vois des nouveaux
supports qui arrive je pense qu'il y à
une renaissance potentiel ou une relance
de la civilisation et c'est la raison
pour laquelle est bien le livre doit
garder toute sa place est complété par
les nouveaux supports et les enfants ne
s'y trompe pas qui certes joue avec les
ordinateurs mais sont aujourd'hui 20% de
plus à lire comme 1973 et roanne villes
moyennes illustre bien cet envol de la
lecture on voit l'arrivée à san
francisco d'isabelle autissier qui en
deuxième position soit 5 jours 9 heures
après par les a franchi la ligne de la
route de l'or où l'attendaient ses
parents à ses quais lexandre car à eric
de l'agneau voilà la belle ne s'est pas
perdue elle est juste un peu en retard
un peu en retard au port où ses parents
papa et maman autissier l'attendent
comme chaque fois qu'isabelle met les
voiles
ils sont à l'arrivée fidèle au poste
pour ceux qui restent à terre les
courses c'est une question d'attentes
chez moi non plus
la version 130
oui mais c'est moins lente le vendée
globe et puis en vendée globe il était
tout seul en plus j'aime pas tellement
le solitaire
isabelle autissier c'est un nom propre
un nom déjà dans la légende des marins
de ce bout de femme qui relève les défis
les plus fous on disait qu'elle était
solitaire c'est avec quatre matelots
qu'elle a bouclé le tour des amis pas le
temps de s'ennuyer
on les jours passent les semaines
passent et puis bon la fin est toujours
longue parce qu'on a envie d'arriver
surtout là cette fois ci puisque avait
pas de vent mais en fait on se rend pas
compte que ça fait deux mois qu'on est
en mer cette fois le golden gate c'est
un pont trop loin pour autissier la
reine isabelle conquérante de la route
des clippers qui quatre ans durant à
conserver le record de la distance new
york san francisco s'est incliné devant
la machine à gagner devant yves parlier
l'allemand erik zabel a remporté
aujourd'hui le milan san remo première
grande classique cycliste de la saison
déjà vainqueur l'an dernier rick zabel a
devancé au sprint le français emmanuel
manière et frédéric moncassin
voilà l'arrivée en quarts de finale de
la coupe de france de football lens à
éliminer cet après midi quand un club de
deuxième division 2 1
l'adie mears me sers est l'auteur des
deux but lensois
nous voyons à l'image
les amateurs de bourg peronnas
affronteront demain soir lien en quarts
de finale de la coupe de france à 24
heures de cette rencontre inattendue
florent gautreau et christophe vignal se
sont rendus dans cette petite ville de
lin ou même si le succès les surprend
toujours joué arrêt supporter prépare
activement le match de leur vie
enfin seuls enfin tranquille depuis deux
mois et depuis les deux exploits de son
équipe
pierre mauron l'entraîneur des héros n'a
pas eu une minute à lui pas facile à
assumer pour le meneur du club amateur
je suis employé de la journée f après je
suis aussi entraîneur de football
et puis il faut répondre à toutes les
sollicitations qu'ils soient de
médiatique ou populaire je dirais dans
les rues de bourges c'est souvent qu'on
nous arrête il faut discuter un petit
peu les gens veulent partager un peu de
ce voleur alors on début de semaine
l'entraîneur a tranché interdiction pour
les joueurs de trop se montrer en ville
histoire de réveiller tout le monde
avant les quarts de finale caméra qui
n'étaient pas habitués à ça et c'est
vrai qu'avec un peu de recul on s'est
dit que cette semaine il fallait aller
penser à travailler et à redevenir un
peu nous mêmes ces exploits répétés
c'est une aubaine pour le club mais
aussi et surtout peut-être pour
bourg-en-bresse toute la ville s'est
drapé de bleu et blanc et rares sont les
commerçants qui ont oublié de célébrer
l'équipe locale dans leurs vitrines les
plus man ce sont même des péchés
d'imprimer écharpes maillots et posters
aux couleurs du club
le maire aussi est très présent sur le
marché de madère pour parler football et
pas politique
il a d'ailleurs investi plus de cent
mille francs pour pavoiser la ville la
ville est une entreprise nous avons à
nous faire connaître et il est bien
évident que cette
en compétition a permis donc de mieux
valoriser pour que ces atouts avant le
match de demain il n'y a donc aucun
perdant que des gagnants chez annie au
siège des supporters on a d'ailleurs
déjà commencé à fêter ça hollywood se
prépare lundi à décerner les oscars des
meilleurs films de l'année en
compétition titanic avec neuf
nominations et de full monty meilleur
film étranger ce film qui raconte
l'histoire de cinq chômeurs anglais qui
se reconvertissent dans un spectacle de
strip tease est devenu un film culte en
grande bretagne au point qui est
organisée une visite touristique sur les
lieux mêmes du tournage
etienne leenhardt voici donc la dernière
trouvaille des autorités de la ville de
sheffield pour 80 francs par personne
la visite organisée des sites sur
lesquels ont été tournés les principales
scènes du dernier grand succès du cinéma
britannique the full monty
nous voici donc sur le terrain où nos
héros ont passé beaucoup de temps et
d'énergie à essayer de retrouver leur
ligne
l'histoire de ces cinq chômeurs qu'il
faut sortir du désoeuvrement monte un
spectacle de strip-tease intégral est
une aubaine pour cette ville au passé
industriel révolue nous sommes fiers de
se passer mais nous voulions également
montré combien chef il a changé en
utilisant l'histoire et les lieux du
full monty que tout le monde pourrait
reconnaître
de fait sheffield n'a pas grand chose
d'autres à montrer que les lieux de
tournage du full menti frappée par la
fermeture des mines et des aciéries la
ville s'est peu à peu converti aux
technologies aujourd'hui j'ai filmé ne
compte pas plus de chômeurs que la
moyenne nationale
si dans l'histoire de cinq compères
s'imprègne de leurs spectacles à venir
jusque dans les longues files d'attentes
de l' agence pour l'emploi local
les vrais chômeurs de sheffield de
reconnaître que le film a apporté à leur
ville une grande bouffée d'optimisme
dont les gens avaient besoin ici pour
sortir des larmes monotonie je le
mettrais à poil pour rien au monde
dan et combien question argent tout va
bien merci le film devrait à terme
rapporter plus d'un milliard de francs
par ailleurs le lancement de la cassette
vidéo suscite de bien curieuses vocation
l'artère commerçante de londres s'est
retrouvé bloqué récemment par une meute
de curieux en vitrine cinq adeptes
plutôt bedonnant du full monty mais ces
images ne sont pas rassurantes car si
d'aventuré le film décroche un oscar à
hollywood
le full monty risque bien de devenir un
véritable sport national en france à
l'affiché depuis mercredi le nouveau
film de jacques rivette secret défense
quatre ans après jeanne la pucelle il
offre à sandrine bonnaire un nouveau
rôle celui d'une jeune femme
d'aujourd'hui confronté à une
mystérieuse affaire de famille parce
qu'elle défend jean louis normandin
c'était le passé dans la nuit du 15 mai
dernier
je ne peux pas le dire à l'accident
s'est levé non pas exactement un crime
alors secret défense est l'histoire d'un
secret de famille parce que les familles
comme les états ont leurs zones d'ombré
tout commence lorsque sylvie rousseau
apprend de la bouche de son jeune frère
que leur père mort quatre ans plus tôt
en fait été assassiné pour empêcher son
frère de commettre l'irréparable
elle décide seul d'éliminer le coupable
mais au cours d'une bagarre elle tuera
la maîtresse de celui ci une jeune femme
de son âge
la voici à son tour une meurtrière sera
qu'au départ on avait envie de
d'un basculement comme ça de
chamboulement de vie en fait l'idée
c'était de revenir un peu à dostoïevski
toute cette culpabilité comme ça d'un
crime et châtiment ou ce type là dessus
cette femme et et c'est tout ce que ça
comporte quoi cette espèce de de
mauvaise conscience et de poids comme ça
c'est assez lourd d'avoir tué et deux et
que pas que sa vie sa vie est foutue en
fait après je lui parlerai le comprendra
n'en voulait pas de réponse je crois
qu'il vaut mieux comme on reste là vous
ne parlerez pas passionner plus là le
cinéma de rivette prend son temps avec
ses longs plans ses cadres large dans
lesquels s'ébattent les personnages
aussi comme s'il avait dans l'espace la
liberté qu'ils ont perdus dans leurs
têtes vie mais crier pas su pas soudain
je crois qu'un film à son propre rythme
un film peuples prennent un film d'une
heure trente peut être terriblement long
ou un film de trois heures pour passer
très bien moi je crois que c'est plus
lié à comment on traite le sujet comment
commencer film et comment comment les
acteurs jouent dans ce polar
psychologique on s'intéresse plus aux
être qu'au coup de revolver c'est
pourquoi on s'identifie sans effort
sylvie sorte d' hamlet ou d'electre des
temps modernes perdu dans ces pauvres
rêve de vengeance
depuis quelques minutes appelle la
naissance d'une nouvelle chaîne de
télévision la chaîne de la musique de
l'opéra et de la danse de baptiser l'exo
7 chaîne diffuse sa soirée inaugurale
sur satellite et sur le câble
une chaîne thématique de france
télévisions avec de nombreux rendez vous
reportage louis carzou pascal garbarini
comme une bonne nouvelle n'arrive jamais
seule le retour du printemps voit
également la naissance de mezzo fille de
france 2 arte la 5e et france télécom
cette nouvelle chaîne vient en lieu et
place de france supervision avec pour
programme toute la musique que l'on aime
de la viole de gambe aux envols des
étoiles métaux entend se consacrer au
domaine du classique de l'opéra de la
danse sans oublier le jazz accessible
sur le satellite et le câble ou mezzo va
devoir affronter la concurrence de
musique et de musique classique
cette chaîne a pour ambition
d'intéresser le public le plus large
cette chaîne voudrait développer aussi
une programmation pour les enfants et
pour les jeunes et nous avons
sélectionnés notamment le dimanche matin
à rennes mercredi un certain nombre de
programmes qui peuvent éveiller le
l'intérêt des jeunes pour la musique
avec de l'opéra l'heure du goûter et des
documentaires musicaux à des horaires
familiaux mezzo entend enrichir vos yeux
et vos oreilles sans moderato
retour à l'actualité politique je vous
le disais au début de ce journal le
front national revendique ce soir la
réciprocité en demandant la présidence
de la région provence alpes et côte
d'azur
et voici la réponse de michel vauzelle
qui est candidat socialiste à la
présidence il dit je le cite on descend
peu à peu dans l'abomination c'est
l'extrême droite plurielle qui réclame
son denier après avoir passé des marchés
fin de citation et nous reviendrons
évidemment sur cette actualité politique
tout au long du journal dès 13 heures et
demain dans une édition spéciale
consacrée à lui aux élections cantonales
c'est la fin de cette édition je vous en
rappelle le principal titre après le
meurtre de l'affectif de ludivine
médecins et psychologues entoure les
élèves qui sont rentrés chez eux
le suspect le cuisinier du camp est
passé aux aveux dans un instant la météo
isabelle martinez nuages au nord et au
sud températures en baisse
à 20h55 vival l'eurovision présenté par
dave de master dans thé ou café
catherine ceylac reçoit juliette gréco
j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver
demain soir 20h merci de votre attention
très belle soirée se passait